what I do think about is confluence of
different technologies suddenly becoming
a big enabler of a revolutionary new
step self-driving vehicles were enabled
by advances in sensing capability
electronics becoming smaller faster and
cheaper and then when you combine that
with artificial intelligence
improvement that we have seen over the
past decade or so that in turn is
enabling the creation and deployment of
synthetic vehicles if we are able to
sense all activities happening within a
metropolitan region things happening in
transportation water sewage air quality
noise quality law enforcement healthcare
you name it if you can basically sense
those things process that with the
enormous amounts of computational power
that we have at our disposal today and
then run a on it we can actually extract
inferences trends and patterns which can
be exploited fed back to citizens
planners decision-makers employers and
long-term planners they can literally
make cities actually operate much more
efficiently and effectively making them
smarter and metropolitan lives like they
have a much better quality of life
there's not just about innovations in
technology that needs to be innovations
in policy as well so the the
improvements in policy and technology
really have to work with each other it's
not job-related technology's just doing
that in their individual labs the
Dodgers about policy makers making
decisions in a vacuum means exactly get
this or two groups of people working
together talking to each other in the
same room
you